[Boys and girls are in a classroom listening to a teacher.]
[The teacher is pointing to words written on the chalkboard.]
[On the chalkboard is written "To give form to the face" and "Sound teeth do the best work"]
[Close-up of the chalkboard. There are words written on it; "Why you need teeth", "What they do", "To cut and grind the food."]
[Close-up of a model of a mouth with teeth. The model is moved to show the action of the teeth.]
["To give form to the face" is written on the blackboard.]
[A model of a boy's face is shown.]
[An inset of the boy's mouth before dental work is shown to compare to the current, improved condition of the mouth. The inset shows an overbite, with teeth protruding on the top.]
[Another model is shown with an inset. The model shows a jaw pushed out; the mouth is closed. The inset depicts protruding lower teeth.]
[Written on the blackboard is "To aid personal appearance."]
[A close-up of a young boy with discolored and rotting teeth is shown.]
[The pictures gradually change to show the boy with attractive, cleaned and repaired teeth.]
["Sound straight teeth do the best work" is written on the chalkboard.]
[A model of a mouth is shown.]
[The model is opened up to show the inside of the mouth.]
[A pointer points at the teeth.]
[All strong and healthy. Yours should be.]
[A teacher stands among a classroom filled with girls and boys. The children are raising their hands.]
[The teacher calls on one boy who stands up to talk.]
[What causes a cavity in a tooth?]
[The boy sits back down at his desk.]
[Imperfect places in the enamel and unbalanced nutrition.]
[A dental instrument shows dark spots in the depressions on the top of single model tooth.]
[The starchy foods remain there, forming an acid.]
[Model of single tooth with the depressions filled with dark matter.]
[Cross section of a molar]
[A model of a single tooth is being sawed in half to show a cross section.]
[The cross section of a tooth is shown.]
[A pointer shows the decay in the crevices of the model tooth.]
[The decay gets bigger and invades the interior of the model tooth.]
[It should be filled at once!]
[The decay spreads even farther in the model tooth]
[The teacher is talking to the students in the classroom]
[The children raise their hands]
[How does a cavity in a tooth affect the rest of the body?]
[The boy who asked the question is standing at his desk as the teacher replies: ]
[A good question. I suggest that you ASK YOUR DENTIST]
[The teacher continues speaking to the student, who has his back to the camera as the teacher faces him.]
[The boy is standing in front of a door. The door is mostly glass and the name on the door is "Dr. Early Care, Dentist."]
[The boy enters the dentist's office.]
[The boy looks around. There are chairs and wall sconces and a chandelier.]
[A nurse comes over and puts her hand on the boy's arm.]
[The dentist enters the room through an arched doorway. He is a tall man with a mustache. He and the boy shake hands,
[The boy talks to the dentist while the nurse looks on.]
[The boy asks the dentist a question.]
[Doctor, how does a cavity in a tooth affect the rest of the body?]
[The dentist is facing the camera and the boy is facing the dentist. The dentist talks to the boy.]
[Come with me, into the visual instruction room.]
[The dentist takes the boy by the arm and leads him away as the nurse watches.]
[The boy and the dentist are seated in chairs with their backs to the camera.]
[There is a film projector on the left and the boy watches the film being played.]
[The dentist is now seated next to a desk and the boy is seated near. The dentist has a tooth model on the desk and the boy looks at it.]
[Under each cavity is the pulp or nerve.]
[Close-up of a tooth model. There is a pointer showing a big cavity in the tooth.]
[This nerve dies causing infection at the root end.]
[The model is shown again with the pointer indicating the nerve root.]
[The dentist and the boy are shown again at the desk.There is a box with x-ray slides on the desk.]
[An x-ray of teeth is shown. One tooth has a very large cavity.]
[General Germ sends his enemy army through the blood stream.]
[An animated tooth model shows the cavity and infection spreading to the tooth root and beyond.]
[Animated germs, shown as ovals are going into the blood stream.]
[The ovals turn into little men and one is bigger than the rest. This figure orders the germs into formation.]
[The leader of the germs opens a trapdoor and orders the germs into it. They file down in formation as the leader watches them.]
[An animated figure of a human body is shown. The infection spreads from the top of the figure to the bottom.]
[The germs are shown marching down a road being led by the larger germ.]
[Some of the germs are shown turning down a road which is marked by a sign "To the Heart".]
[Some of the germs are shown turning down a road which is marked by a sign "To the Eyes."]
[Some of the germs are shown turning down a road which is marked by a sign "To the Joints."]
[Some of the germs are shown turning down a road which is marked by a sign "To the Kidneys."]
[The dentist and boy are shown at the desk again.]
[The dentist opens up a book and shows it to the boy.]
[Dental Infection and Systemic Disease by Russell L. Haden, M.A., M.D. Professor of Experimental Medicine, University of Kansas School of Medicine, Kansas City, Kansas.]
[Root end cultures were made from over three thousand teeth.]
[A woman is shown holding a test tube. She puts it into an incubator.]
[Germs grow rapidly at body temperature in the incubator.]
[The woman closes the door to the incubator.]
[A man is seated at a bench which has bottles and test tubes on shelves behind it. The man is leaning over a microscope and is adjusting it.]
[The slide on the microscope is shown.]
[600 patients, with various diseases, were studied. Bacteria from their infected teeth, caused similar diseases in rabbits.]
[Rabbits are shown with bedding and dishes in a cage. Underneath the picture it says, "Their tissues and circulation are similar to ours".]
[From Dr. Haden's book, page 95. Case 11 history--R.K., A salesman, age 27, complained of rheumatism, came in on crutches.]
[A man on crutches is slowly walking down a corridor. He stops in front of a door which says "Dental Surgeon, X-ray Diagnosis".]
[The man opens the door and enters.]
[The dentist and the boy look at x-rays in a box on the desk.]
[The dentist points out dark spots on the roots of two teeth.]
[Cultures from his teeth when injected in rabbit caused marked joint and kidney disease--]
[Upon removal of the infection, the patient recovered completely.]
[The dentist and the boy are shown again.]
[A man gets out of a car and reaches for his briefcase.]
[Another man approaches the car and they shake hands.]
[Hello R.K., where are the crutches?]
[The men continue to talk standing by the car.]
[Oh boy, feeling fine now, it was all from my teeth, I'll not neglect them again!]
[The second man gets into the car and the car's owner walks away.]
[The dentist and the boy are seated by the desk. The dentist shows the boy a book.]
[Dr. Haden explains many similar cases. His research also shows that infected teeth do produce disease in--]
[A human figure is shown and areas are labeled; Eyes, Joints, Heart, Kidneys, Joints.]
[The dentist and the boy are again seated at the desk.]
[The boy is talking to the dentist.]
[I understand now, but what should we do about it?]
[The boy looks at the dentist.]
[Prevention]
[Three essentials to grow and maintain sound healthy teeth.]
[Picture of a tooth with a cutout showing food inside it, marked Secret Inside. Nutrition: Right foods build strong teeth in childhood and keep them sound.]
[Foods that supply tooth building materials. MILK is first.]
[A tooth is shown with a milk bottle in front of it.]
[Leafy Vegetables Come Next: Tomatoes, Carrots, Onions, Turnips, Cabbage, Celery, Lettuce, Spinach]
[A tooth is shown with vegetables floating towards and landing atop it.]
[Whole Grains: Whole Wheat, Scotch Oatmeal, Whole Cornmeal, Brown Rice]
[A stalk of wheat is shown, followed by a loaf of bread.]
[The bread floats toward the tooth model, followed by a bottle of cod liver oil]
[Your teeth must be fed every day to keep them sound throughout life.]
[Signs read: Nutrition -- Right foods build strong teeth in childhood and keep them sound. ]
[A model of a tooth with a window labeled Secret Inside displays healthy foods inside the tooth.]
[Signs read: Cleanliness -- Equally Important -- Clean Teeth - Clean Dishes - Clean Food]
[Camera pans down to title reading Dr. W.J. Charters - Method of Brushing, from "Dental Digest"]
[Beneath that are molds of upper and lower teeth and the correct position of the toothbrush upon the teeth.]
[Close-ups of the teeth and the brush]
[This method cleans between the teeth and massages the gums.]
[Close-ups of the teeth and the brush demonstrating brushing techniques on the inside, outside, and tops of teeth.]
[Views of a mold of teeth and beside it a toothbrush, and a bottle of tooth powder]
[Signs read: Dental Care Will Save Your Teeth / Is Health Care]
[Dr. Early Care, Dentist]
[Animated sequence of germs trying to attack a home through a window and being chased away by healthy foods.]
[The boy and the dentist are shown talking.]
[Always Remember]
[--that Dental Care is Health Care]
[The boy and the dentist shake hands.]
[The End]